this is one that that broke during our
our hiatus and i it was two weeks ago i
think today when the news first hit
i'm still astounded by the decision by
anyone in today's nfl to commit for 12
years i don't care about the numbers and
the numbers aren't aren't who knows what
the numbers are going to be when i first
saw
that he had signed a 10-year extension
to put him under contract for 12 years
chris you know what my first thought was
oh i know my first thought was we
finally have a guy who has been
guaranteed a percentage of the salary
cap every year of his career because how
else do you protect yourself against
ongoing growth of the cap ongoing growth
of the market because 45 million per
year in new money on that 10-year
extension by the time we get yeah to
year 10 of the extension nothing
somebody's gonna be making more than 45
million dollars a year somebody's gonna
make a lot more than 45 million a year
and there's no device for patrick holmes
to force a renegotiation the chiefs can
say hey this is the contract you signed
and we're gonna we're gonna honor it and
we expect you to honor it and we'll go
back to the table when it's time for
this contract to expire yeah well i mean
come on you know that's nice of you to
say but we know that's not the reality
we can very easily get to year three or
four of this contract and mahomes has
had three or four years of throwing 50
touchdown passes and you know he's won
another super bowl and another mvp and
he can go you know what hey two or three
other guys they signed for you know more
money than me i'd like a new contract i
don't think kansas city is gonna be like
screw you patrick mahomes you're done
would he do that i know what would he do
that i don't i don't think he's inspired
to do that i don't think he is either
and i think he showed us that it's very
refreshing i mean i i i know i know you
don't like it i know it's not you you
apparently look all right sorry i i
think that the best player in football
should be paid accordingly screw me for
thinking that i mean i don't get this
attitude chris that you think guys
should just forgo the appropriate
compensation for their skills and
abilities and sacrifices just for the
benefit of helping the team what would
have been wrong with saying patrick
mahomes gets 17 of the salary cap every
year for the next 12 years that leaves
83 cents on the dollar to put a team
around him no matter how many cap
dollars there are what would have been
wrong with that why don't you do that i
i don't know why they don't do that but
they didn't and then you know listen
don't worry he doesn't care so he's
happy with what he's getting well you
know some people are okay living in
their hometown and a big house on the
hill and just being good like that you
know i know a guy that does that ah wait
wait wait
oh that's right some people are happy
that way not everybody needs to move
today okay but you know what i'm saying
and listen you know also this is a guy
that i think yes he's not looking for
every last dollar i think he's into this
like for real i'm not saying every last
dog i know but i'm just saying every
last time i know i'm just saying i think
he's in for this for real like to be the
greatest of all time he's trying to show
you but doing this right here you know
he's kind of taking the old chris sims
line like you know it's not going to
matter if i got 150 million in the bank
or 135 million in the bank i'm still
going to have everything i want in the
world but because i took 135 million in
the bank or whatever that number i'm
just you know throwing something out
there he might win three or four more
super bowls and you know it's hard when
all the time we always praise tom brady
praise tom brady and praise tom brady
hey and then
you know he wants something tom brady
tom tom brady didn't do it i know he'd
be a good teammate tom brady was forced
because he was afraid of bill belichick
right he was afraid that he was going to
get cut or traded i know bill belichick
looked at that cap number looked at the
film and said i'm going to do to brady
what i did to drew bledsoe that's why
tom brady listen i've been trying to say
this
you're right i know
that's absolutely right
it's not he's being a good teammate how
about this about this yes if if i if i'm
gonna be a good teammate and i'm gonna
leave salary cap space behind
why is it part of the negotiation that
if you don't spend it all i get it
right if if if whatever you've got yeah
i'll do i'll do a cap friendly deal i'll
do a team-friendly deal but you got to
use it all and any amount of the salary
cap that you don't use in a given year i
get it what's wrong with that why didn't
a guy say that i i don't know i mean you
know i didn't i don't know that's it's a
good idea i mean you should have called
steinberg sports and mahomes before that
and let them know that one uh but i i
think ultimately really and i don't
think this is a big surprise and you
know i i think this is a guy that one
has shown us he's chris
it's a big surprise to commit for 12
years there's no reason to commit for 12
years no do a four-year deal or a
five-year deal there's no reason to sign
up for 12 years when you cannot force a
renegotiation no and who knows how
different that team is going to be 12
years from now what if clark hunt sells
you're committed to that team through
2030. i know well we know that he can
wiggle his way out if he's not happy we
do but yeah this is the ultimate example
of a team friendly deal it's like the
most team friendly deal i've ever seen a
superstar player give a team i i mean
i'm not trying to argue against you here
i agree it was it was shocking you know
when they first heard the number i went
whoa whoa they're gonna get 500 million
dollars then i was like what 12 years
and you started to break it down you
went damn this is like what i mean when
you really break it down i i should have
brought it up it's basically like what a
five-year 130 million dollar contract at
the start i mean it's the greatest thing
ever
yeah the cash flow isn't always told i
know it was always told
three things to look at with the
contract yeah signing bonus because
that's the money in the bank we talked
earlier about the between signing bonus
and guaranteed salary yeah the only true
guarantee is the signing bonus
guaranteed salary fully guaranteed at
signing and cash flow for the first
three years all three of those factors
on the mahomes deal stink all three of
them 10 million signing bonus the full
guarantee of signing is like 62 million
which is a joke when you consider his
talent and the three-year cash flow we
did the math dak prescott is in a much
better shape going year to year under
the franchise to have much better shots
oh i'm sure tannehill's in better shape
over the next three years from a cash
flow standpoint yeah than patrick
mahomes and then after the three years
you're committed for nine more i i just
i i'm still stunned by it two weeks ago
well i mean when you saw patrick mahomes
sign for that contract i went well
there's no way
doc prescott's getting a contract with
dallas now i just knew that was gonna
happen too because it just was like what
i mean
dallas is probably like what you want as
much money as my homes look what he just
took so
i knew that would be trouble there but i
think really legitimately mahomes looks
at it and he goes man chris jones we
needed him on our team he's one of the
best defensive players in football i
think he thinks about guys like honey
badger and you know travis kelsey and
tyree kill and he understands that those
guys are huge
into
you know helping the stardom of which we
know patrick mahomes is now i mean they
were huge in that and i i think he just
he's looking to make a run that way it's
shocking yes is it undervalued yes but
uh i i guess the thing that bothered me
more than anything was probably like you
said mike the money the guaranteed and
the signing bonus that's where i was
like
you know i'm all for taking the team
friendly deal i don't know if i would
have gone that far you know like right i
mean what did aaron rodgers got what a
hundred million guaranteed right you
know for injury and things like that i
thought he was no fully guaranteed fully
guaranteed right mahomes has 140 million
guaranteed for injury but but let's face
it how many truly catastrophic
career-ending injuries are there for
quarterbacks alex smith joe theismann
yeah steve young right pretty much right
it does not happen a whole lot you're
right and uh yeah so listen they're
lucky that's all i could say kansas city
is lucky that they have a guy that is
truly a superstar who's you know this is
like michael jordan back with the bulls
remember when he was making like two or
three million dollars a year until the
last three years he played with the
bulls i mean mahomes seems to be fine
with taking that and and just seeing
where it goes
i i think that
for the agent it was all about being
able to sell headline the
biggest contract in sports history half
a billion dollars i i was joking on
radio during our hiatus about it i said
yes i'd like to announce i have a half
billion dollar contract with nbc
i just have to live the next thousand
years
so you can get a half billion if you're
willing to commit for 12 years you can
get a half billion if you're patrick
mahomes and that's exactly what happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports